i want to take you on a little trip down
memory lane all the way back to 2005
when an eccentric movie star gave an
infamous interview on the today show
here's the problem you don't know the
history of psychiatry i do all it does
is mask the problem matt and if you
understand the history of it it masks
the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance and i'm saying that drugs
aren't the answer that these these drugs
are very dangerous they're mind altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in a brave new world yes
there are abuses and yes maybe they've
gone too far in certain areas maybe
there are too many kids on ritalin maybe
electric shock kids unrealistic i'm just
saying but but aren't there examples
where it works
you don't even you're glib you don't
even know what ritalin is if you start
talking about chemical imbalance you
have to evaluate and read the research
papers on how they came up with these
theories matt okay that's what i've done
you and you go and you say where's
where's the medical test
for that interview tom cruise was turned
into a national laughing stock he nearly
lost his career and he was called crazy
crazy not like everyone in hollywood is
crazy which they are
but especially crazy crazy because he
contradicted the medical establishment
which had been making money hand over
fist slinging depression pills to treat
an alleged chemical imbalance in the
brain on the one side of the issue you
had a kooky weirdo movie star
on the other side you had the entire
public health authority
guess who was right
a new meta-analysis that has just come
out
looking at studies involving
tens of thousands of people has
concluded that the chemical imbalance
theory is
completely bogus
most depression pills are what is called
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
ssris which are said to work by
correcting abnormally low serotonin
levels
this scientific review which was
published in the journal molecular
psychiatry finds quote no clear evidence
that low serotonin levels are
responsible for depression in the words
of the study's lead author a psychiatry
professor at university college london
and consultant psychiatrist at northeast
london nhs foundation trust quote
many people take antidepressants because
they believe and have been led to
believe their depression has a
biochemical cause
but this new research suggests this
belief is not grounded in evidence
after a vast amount of research
conducted over several decades there is
no convincing evidence that depression
is caused by serotonin abnormalities
particularly by lower levels or reduced
activity of serotonin now
this seems like a pretty important
finding for the 85 to 90 percent of the
public that according to surveys
believes in the chemical imbalance
theory
this seems like a really big finding for
the millions of americans one in eight
who take these depression pills to
correct a chemical imbalance that
apparently does not exist
for the 1 in 29 american teenagers and
younger
who have been prescribed these drugs
under false pretenses
and it's good that after decades of
pharmaceutical companies peddling these
drugs often through incessant tv
commercials touting the theory and
minimizing the considerable side effects
it's good that now it's come out that
there was never any scientific evidence
for the theory that's good better late
than never but it leaves one nagging
question
how did tom cruise know this back in
2005 how did a guy
whose job it is to look good on camera
know more about psychiatry than the
entire medical establishment and
mainstream media 17 years before this
analysis came out forget tom cruise for
a second
forget the depression drugs for a second
how is it how is it that a bunch of
weirdo bloggers and fringy tweeters and
alex jones a frequently shirtless radio
host who yells into a microphone how is
it that all those people
have a much better record on covid
and the vaccines than say
dr fauci rachelle walensky the world
health organization and the entire
public health establishment how is it
that i
okay not uh i don't you know i hate to
say i told you so how is it that i a guy
with no higher education
than a bachelor's in history and italian
poetry how is it that i
and most of you most of whom do not have
medical degrees how is it
that every single time we contradicted
the public health establishment and
their propagandists in the press and big
tech on covid over the past few years on
the wuhan lab on mortality rates on the
danger to young people on the efficacy
of the vaccines against infection on the
efficacy of the vaccines against
transmission on the relation between
vaccines and menstruation on the risks
of the mrna technology the list goes on
and on on every single part of it how is
it
that we were always right
and the authorities were always wrong
ignorance on their part
malice
greed
indifference perhaps
whatever it is
it turns out that the people our
establishment has maligned as crazy
for decades
we're right all along
and the only people who seem crazy today
are the ones who still think those
authorities have even one ounce of
credibility i'm michael knowles that's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from cool papa j
magic i have to meet this guy cool papa
j magic has had so many of my favorite
comments he says i love what michael's
saying here people are not taught
anymore that demons are real satan too
and even god for that matter we are in
complete disorder i see what you're
saying which is they're not even taught
that god is real but the way it sounds
is
and even god is real even in addition to
those things when of course god is the
most real god is the source and summit
of all being being himself but you're
right you're right those things are real
as anton and scalia said many more
intelligent people than you and i
have believed in the devil
those things are real that that
spiritual world those spiritual
realities are real certainly certainly
much more real than chemical imbalances
in the brain we just got to communicate
that to people when you want to
communicate with people you got to check
out podium right now go to podium.com
knowles from supply chain issues to
increase demand on top of everything
else that business owners have to manage
the businesses who are thriving right
now are the ones that are forward
thinking
podium helps your small business stay
ahead of the curve with modern messaging
tools that make it easy for your
customers to connect with your business
it is the year of our lord 2022 start
doing business like the companies that
are winning from health care providers
to plumbers over 100 000 businesses are
texting with customers through podium
customers love the convenience
businesses love the results they give
you an example one car dealer just sold
a 50 000 truck in four text messages
that's it super simple that's how people
communicate in their daily lives
businesses have to be there too with
podiums all in one inbox you can do even
more than just chat get more online
reviews by sending an easy to use link
collect payments fast from anywhere and
send marketing campaigns that actually
get a response all by sending a quick
text see how podium can grow your
business watch a demo today at
podium.com knowlesthispodium.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s podium let's grow
speaking of sickness
joe biden has kovit the president of the
united states has covid so announced the
white house doctor white house doctor
kevin o'connor said in a memo that the
president is quote currently
experiencing mild symptoms
mostly rhinorrhea which is not a word
that anyone should use there's no reason
to use it just that means runny nose did
you know that it's a much that's a gross
word no one should use that is
experiencing rhinorrhea and fatigue with
an occasional dry cough which started
yesterday evening so the good news is
seriously i'm not being facetious or
anything here it's good i'm glad joe
biden is a fellow human being we hope he
makes a full recovery i'm glad that he's
a parent apparently it's experiencing
mild symptoms
can't help but notice though
that it's a little bit ironic that joe
biden got
the virus because
you know i won't even explain it i will
take you on a little journey here is a
play in three acts
you're okay you're not gonna you're not
gonna get covet if you have these
vaccinations yeah
[Music]
there he is he's getting a shot
okay
staying there
hey folks guess you heard this morning i
tested positive recovery
but i've been double vaccinated double
boosted
symptoms are mild and uh and i really
appreciate your inquiries and your
concerns
he got covered
he got kova he said if you get the
vaccine you can't get covered and then
he got the vaccine and then he got a
bunch of boosters and then
then he got covered
shouldn't he have to answer for that
shouldn't
he
he spread fake news he's he spread
medical misinformation
people will lose their careers for that
these days they will be de-platformed
for that don't don't the libs broadly
biden in particular but he can't answer
anything don't the libs broadly have to
answer for that
but they're not giving any answers at
all here's another question people are
asking where did biden catch covet you
remember during the trump years
when when trump got covid there was one
time at cpac the conservative political
action conference uh kovid spread at
cpac coincidentally i happened to be in
the green room where kovid's spread and
because there were a number of hot very
high profile administration people there
i i ended up getting put on a bunch of
lists where they said don't don't go
anywhere near michael because kellyanne
conway and
ted cruz was there and there were a
number of other
key administration people and they said
these awful people they were in the room
stay away from them this is a super
spreader conservatives are so
irresponsible
well okay where did biden catch it what
super spreader event was he at the white
house won't answer where was he infected
i don't think we know um i certainly
don't know if you have any thoughts on
look i don't think that that matters
right i think what matters is we
prepared for this moment i think what
matters uh is what dr jaw just laid out
uh if we look at where we were a year
and a half ago this is a president when
he walked in one of his first priorities
was to make sure we had a comprehensive
plan to get people vaccinated and so now
today look look to today more and more
people are getting closer to having a
more normal life
vaccines are available and as dr jah
said if you have not gotten vaccinated
please do if you have not if you're if
you've not gotten boosted please do
these are uh these are treatments that
are going to keep you safe and i think
that's what matters here is making sure
that we continue to do the work and the
good thing is that uh the president
again has been uh vaccinated and double
boosted that's the really important
thing
because could you imagine if he hadn't
been vaccinated and boosted by golly he
might have gotten
he said the thing the white house said
the thing that they always say whenever
the libs who said that if you get the
vaccine you won't get covered and then
they get coveted and they say well thank
goodness i'm vaccinated and boosted
by golly could you imagine how bad it
would be if i
if i hadn't been vaccinated and boosted
no i can't imagine i have no reason to
believe that it would be worse actually
because you people this the very same
people who told me with such certainty
you will not get the virus if you take
the vaccine you will not transmit the
virus if you get the vaccine
you are the very same people who are
telling me yeah well anyway in this kind
of unfalsifiable way it would definitely
be worse so get the vaccine anyway
i i don't know folks i don't know when
you're
when you're wrong about pretty much
every major public health question and
when you lie in some cases i just i'm
not so inclined to believe you
i want i want to i want to speak to
people directly okay i don't want to i
don't want to have to get my information
filtered through these kinds of people
when i want to talk to my friends
directly i use puretalk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast you need to switch to puretalk
for a couple of reasons one because
americans are getting pinched right now
the cost of everything is going up and
unbelievably you can save two-thirds on
your cell phone you ca what are you
paying right now 80 90 bucks a month and
you you are paying it to those same
three or four big cell phone companies
what if i told you you can get the same
quality talk text data for way way less
money if you switch to pure talk same
phones same highest and coolest phones
it's just amazing same fabulous 5g
network so that's one reason you've got
to switch it's you're just throwing
money out the window right now people
can't afford to do that right now
the other reason is puretalk sponsors
the voicemail bag which is my favorite
segment of the show these guys are great
supporters of the show they've they're a
veteran-owned company with a customer
service team right here in america as
american as apple pie go to puretalk.com
right now select a plan enter promo code
knowles podcast and on top of the
already amazing savings you can say 50
on your first month switch over today it
takes less than 10 minutes which is
insane i know it's insane because we've
been so battered around by the cell
phone companies puretalk will make it
super easy save you a lot of money promo
code knowles podcast k-w-l-e-s
p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com
speaking of being sick in the head a
second grade teacher
has just uh posted i i assume this was a
tick tock was this libs of tick tock of
course lives of tick tock the one of the
greatest journalistic outlets around
today
uh there's a second grade teacher
who has some sort of queer identity
and she just
posted a really amazing story her entire
second grade class just came out to her
as transgender
okay so it took a couple days for me to
make this tick tock um
without crying because
that's what i do please ignore the dog
bone crunching behind me anyhow um
one of my students uh felt safe enough
to share his pronouns with me
and
when he did so
once the class knew that i knew they all
switched pronouns
they're second graders
like i'm torn between being really
really happy to be a safe space
and just absolutely furious that an
entire group of second graders has to
keep this secret from not safe
people
why are kids feeling unsafe
and
furthermore why does everyone talk about
how how are the kids gonna understand
the kids understand it
it's easy for them it's the adults who
have all of the freaking issues and
hang ups and bullsh kids are fine so
this woman said one true thing in that
statement she when she said it's the
adults who have the hang-ups and the
issues
yes one adult in particular in this
situation has a lot of hang-ups and
issues and is very confused about her
sex and the relationship that she's
supposed to have to students to little
kids who are not her kids and the
relationship that those kids are
supposed to have to their parents who
she derides as unsafe people
does this woman
seriously believe
that her entire class of second graders
what is the second graders
seven years old if you're five years old
in kindergarten is seven years old an
entire class of seven year olds
all of them were born in the wrong body
all of them a hundred percent
of
seven-year-olds
are who look like boys they're actually
secretly girls and ones who look like
girls are actually secretly boys and
that's do you think that's the
explanation or do you think they just
have a weirdo teacher who is confusing
them
which do you think it is obviously i
mean none of you
if you're listening to this show you
definitely have some common sense you
you know what the answer is i don't know
what that woman believes
it's hard for me to believe that she
could be so stupid as to think that an
entire class of seven-year-olds just
happens to all have this very very rare
psychological condition
this sexual delusion where you think
you're the opposite sex
must know she must realize that what
she's doing is pushing a radical sexual
agenda that
really is a cult it is a weird gnostic
religious movement that makes very
outlandish claims about human nature and
who we are and the relationship that the
soul has to the body and like all cults
tells kids to cut off their parents
tells people to cut out their family
your family is awful your family they're
they're trying to harm you
they're they're they're not as
enlightened as we are just talk to us
talk to us about your sexuality kids
don't and you know that's the other
thing about cults is they always have a
weird sexual component
99 times out of a hundred that cult
leader is getting frisky with the ladies
in the cult i don't know it's so strange
how all these prophets all these all
these modern day prophets and religious
leaders and cult leaders how they always
seem to have
how they're always getting messages from
from beyond this realm to sleep with all
the ladies isn't that kind of weird
and and you're getting a similar effect
here with these groomers
it's just
a cult and the question is
do
do you in the name of equality and
tolerance and open-mindedness and
liberality need to tolerate
a
publicly funded institution
to which you send your children to send
them into a cult
a weird creepy sex cult that teaches
them to hate their parents and to
disbelieve reality and to hate their own
bodies
do you think you have to do that i don't
think you do i think the teacher should
be fired i think these ideologies should
be banned from schools i think the books
that peddle these ideologies should be
banned from schools they should be
burned okay i'm going to go a little
further let's go all the way
all right book burning has a long
history in western civilization plato
supported book burning the apostles
supported book burning
certain catholic theologians supported
book burning the leading protestant
theologians supported book burning i
don't love martin luther he's not my
main man he supported book burning too
we've had lots of this in early america
they supported book burning
now
i'm not
i'm not suggesting that we take this so
far
i actually i'm a very open-minded person
i really like tolerance i tolerate all
sorts of crazy ideas i talk to radicals
all the time but there
there is a difference between being a
kind of open-minded interesting
tolerant person who is curious about
other ideas
and supporting with your taxpayer
dollars a weirdo cult that indoctrinates
your kids in the sacred texts of this
insane
leftist
religious ideology
okay there's a big difference here and
we don't need to tolerate that and we
don't need to tolerate these weirdos
turning their kid turning the students
in their class against their parents you
don't have you can just fire them we
have the political right to do that do
we have the political will i'm not so
sure but we do have the political right
to do that speaking of weird sex stuff
and public health
monkey pox is spreading like not like
wildfire it's spreading actually very
very slowly but it is spreading in
america and it's spreading specifically
in
on the coasts in very liberal cities
among homosexual men
that's where it's spreading and the la
times
has figured out why monkey pox is
spreading
the la times has a headline why are we
botching the monkey box response blame
homophobia
this guy senator scott weiner who is a
state senator in san francisco
uh he says we are on our own as always
his name is weiner just going to leave
that there we are on our own as always
we can't count on anyone else ramp and
homophobia is why why monkey pox is
spreading that is not true
monkey pox is spreading because
certain
gay men are having orgies and they just
shouldn't just don't do that if they
didn't do that they wouldn't catch
monkey box
what they're suggesting here is that we
need
to
mobilize our entire public health
apparatus to take on the monkey pox
issue why don't we have enough vaccines
because there is no monkey pox vaccine
because the the vaccine that people are
getting against monkey pox is actually a
smallpox vaccine and why don't we have a
monkeypox vaccine because monkeypox was
never a big issue and it's only
spreading right now because of a belgian
fetish conference and spanish bathhouses
for gay men and if they didn't go to the
bath houses and they didn't go to the
weird fetish orgies
there wouldn't be monkey pox spreading
around okay it would still be confined
to zaire and a few small places in
africa
that have been dealing with this problem
for about 50 years but it hasn't really
spread too much it hasn't become a
massive problem
let's let's go further maybe they'll say
well look we we were able to
gin up the entire public health
apparatus to create a covid vaccine
you saw how well that turned out
why can't we do that to create a monkey
box vaccine why can't we do that to well
because kovid
spread like wildfire it infected pretty
much everybody it could be pretty tough
on certain vulnerable populations it
shut down the world
in terms of the governments shutting
down the economies and so there
there was a pretty good political
argument for that and and you couldn't
avoid having kovid by changing your
personal behavior that that was one of
the ironies of kovit is people thought
that by wearing a special mask or by
even taking a special shot they would
avoid getting coveted and that didn't
happen
pretty much everybody has had kovit and
lots of people have had covered multiple
i've had covered multiple times
i suspect many of you have as well
monkey pox is not the same
you can avoid getting monkey pox you're
not you're not going to get it by riding
the subway you're not going to get it by
going to work you're not going to get it
by going to the store
don't have gay orgies and you won't get
monkey pox that's it but we are told in
our society you're not allowed to say
that you're not allowed to to
recommend that people not have gay
orgies that's a political right gay
orgies are a natural right that's why
james madison wrote the constitution was
to enshrine the right to belgian fetish
conferences so if you'd you have the
right to keep and bear leather ball gags
or something no you don't none of that
is a right we absolutely as a political
community can discourage that sort of
thing and we should discourage that sort
of thing and it would do a hell of a lot
more for the public health than most of
the coveted response and
and the shenanigans that big pharma has
been up to for the past several decades
no question
speaking of weird sex stuff speaking of
sexual rights
the house of representatives the
democrats are taking on the real big
issues
the democrats have just put up the right
to contraception act
the right the right to condoms bill
right now we've got record high
inflation
we've got the first major war in europe
in 70 years we've got record high
illegal immigration millions of foreign
nationals pouring across our border we
still have the public health issues of
the the hangover from kobe we've got all
these problems and they say you know the
big issue
condoms
does anyone have trouble getting condoms
in america or the pill or any other no
it's everywhere it's ever it's
ubiquitous
but the right to contraception act would
quote protect a person's ability to
access contraceptives and to engage in
contraception and to protect the
healthcare providers ability to provide
contraceptives contraception and
information related to contraception
they're doing this because
abortion was a big loser for the dems
and they couldn't argue against the
dobbs decision and they couldn't really
argue against the overruling of roe v
wade and it doesn't poll very well so
they're trying to make that decision
about other issues that are not at risk
they're trying to make that decision
about the redefinition of marriage in
obergefell
they're trying to make that issue about
the
constitutional right so discovered in in
lawrence v texas to homosexual sodomy
they're trying to make it about griswold
v connecticut and eisenstein v baird
which discovered somewhere in the
constitution in 1965 and 1972 the right
the elusive right to put on a condom
first with for married couples and then
for non-married couples too don't know
where that one was in the text probably
between the emanations and the penumbras
written in the invisible ink and so
they're trying to make it about that but
the court in the dobbs decision said
explicitly we are not revisiting
any of those issues contraception
homosexual sodomy even marriage we're
not revisiting any of those clarence
thomas in his concurrence
said we should revisit those things
perhaps he couldn't get any other
justice to sign on none of these things
are at risk whatsoever they are all
ubiquitously available
but the dems have to tilt to windmills
because they can't they can't run any
anything else for the midterms
intelligent
loyal
wise
dignified republicans
would call this out for what it is say
this is such a bs ridiculous distraction
i'm not going to vote for it
and then you've got the squishes
and then you got the squishes
so
you there were two republicans who voted
present on the bill
my problem isn't even with them
people should have voted no on the bill
but my problem isn't even with the two
republicans who voted president my
promise with the eight republicans who
voted yes number one on the list you can
guess who do you think she is
liz cheney of wyoming liz cheney says
yes we absolutely need to enshrine the
right to condoms and birth control and
all that
anthony gonzalez john catko adam
kinzinger brian fitzpatrick nancy mace
fred upton and maria salazar
i
am really glad that republicans have
wised up since the last stupid
ridiculous democrat trap vote the one on
on enshrining the
redefinition of marriage i'm glad 47
republicans voted for that and i read
their names on this show and i think
they're just
absolutely
very disappointing people okay
i'm glad that that number went from 47
to 8
since
since we read those names but these
eight i mean these guys are just
completely worthless
in politics they they should be removed
from the republican party
if if the numbers are anywhere near
right for what we're looking at in the
midterm elections
the republicans are going to have a way
bigger than eight seat majority
so these guys we should throw them out
of the party i mean a lot of them aren't
coming back liz cheney is almost
certainly going to lose adam kinzinger
is certainly not going to come back so
there are a lot of people like that but
it's pathetic now
there's the democrat view which is that
to get into the actual issue of
contraception
is the democrat view that we have an
absolute constitutional right to condoms
and birth control that's just not true
even if you like condoms and birth
control pills and iuds and all that
stuff it's not in the constitution right
if it were in the constitution how come
it took until 1965 to discover it and
how come in 1965 when the supreme court
discovered this alleged right how come
they said no the right only exists for
married couples and it took another
seven years for the court to i don't
know they got out a bigger magnifying
glass in the constitution they said oh
no actually no we missed it in this
paragraph it's for unmarried couples too
yeah it's right there
it's really deep in the substantive due
process you know that contradiction in
terms that ridiculous
liberal legal theory that has that has
allowed the libs to shred the
constitution so even if you support it
it's obviously not in the constitution
right but a really popular view
even among some conservatives is
look birth control it's not in the
constitution but it's a good thing
birth control is a good thing we should
support it
it's great if we don't want to have
abortions we gotta have birth control
as though as though you can only have
one or the other as though as though you
at least need to have one of those
things
and
that's a popular view but here's my
unpopular view
in some quarters
birth control is bad
it's a bad thing and we should
discourage it not saying pass a national
ban i'm not saying that that's not going
to happen like the democrats are yelling
about but it's a bad thing
can we all agree it's a bad thing
no maybe we can all agree that what
about if we look at the history of birth
control you ever look into just google
like what's the history of birth control
birth control the modern birth control
movement comes in the 19 teens and it
was popularized by margaret sanger the
founder of planned parenthood it was a
eugenicist movement
to allegedly improve the race by
stopping undesirable people from
producing kids
that's what it was for
it specifically was aimed at at cutting
the black population and the population
of people with a lower iq all those
stupid idiots they shouldn't be able to
have kids that was what it was for
that's what it was popularized for
margaret sanger i think coined the term
birth control
do you think that campaigns that were
initiated by margaret sanger by one of
the worst human beings ever in the
history of our country do you think that
they're all just like totally hunky-dory
there's not a chance that maybe there's
something a little bit wrong with them
furthermore don't you think
that some of the side effects of birth
control have been sort of bad for our
country like for instance uh encouraging
a culture of promiscuous sex which has
hurt women it's led to this what they
call the rape culture the metoo movement
it's it's hurt men too by causing them
to just
become unaccountable irresponsible it's
caused people to delay marriage quite a
lot it's destroyed the birth rate in the
united states we've had a below
replacement birth rate for 50 years now
where the country is literally dying
that's not it's probably not good either
it severs
the connection between sex and
procreation that can't be a great thing
and it's just kind of anti-human right
that's what that's what those movements
that's what planned parenthood was all
about it's just we want fewer people
people are a kind of pox and plague on
the planet and so we've got to have
fewer people
we don't like all these people
and
and the public health authority really
got behind that
you know the public health authority
that's gotten pretty much everything
wrong
don't you think i'm just asking i'm not
saying you've got to totally come out
and oppose birth control right now i'm
just saying if you kind of think through
it in a way that's not totally
reflexive and you're not if you just
think it's probably not a great thing
right it's probably not a great thing
and i i hope that conservatives start to
get a little bit so especially these
republicans in the house i think i hope
they start to get a little bit deeper in
their thought about how we're talking
about these kinds of things and i just
hope that the republicans stopped being
the democrats from 10 years ago
okay i hope that the republicans are
saying birth control is a great thing i
hope i don't i don't want to have a
republican party that that extols the
virtues of margaret sanger and the
eugenicists you know i just don't think
that's i want a choice
not an echo i'm if i'm going to vote for
two parties and my choices are
the democrats or democrats from 10 years
ago i just i don't even really want to
vote
i want a choice i want a different view
of the world that i can vote for i want
a conservative view of the world that i
can vote for you know we're coming up on
the first month anniversary of the
launch of daily wire plus
which is a huge milestone we could not
have done that without you pat yourself
on the back if you are wondering what to
watch this weekend here are our top
three choices obviously it's mount
walsh's documentary what is a woman it's
a phenomenal documentary took the world
by storm
uh then in honor of his impending
retirement we've got what i think is the
greatest piece of content there on the
daily wire plus platform
the fouchy unmasked docu-series which
goes into detail on all the facts of dr
fauci's life that the liberal media have
covered up and then for a little pallet
cleanser just to
join ben for bench bureau's book club
filmed in israel as he explores leon
eures historical novel and international
bestseller exodus the compelling story
of an american nurse an israeli freedom
fighter the rebirth of a nation there is
so much to watch head on over to
dailywireplus.com become a member today
get 35 off your new membership that is
dailywireplus.com
here we go my absolute favorite time of
the week when i get to hear from you in
the mailbag sponsored by puretalk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code knowles podcast to save 50
off your first month all right before we
get to the written mailbag questions we
have
my favorite the voicemail bag questions
take it away
hi michael my name is lizzy and i love
your show i was just wondering your
thoughts on
why people especially obviously the
liberals and these woke people
why
exactly do they say that
trump is the worst person or the worst
president
in all of history and everything bad is
because of trump and trump ruined the
world and blah blah blah like obviously
i understand that you know he's not this
politician who's you know pretending to
be
the best friend of everyone like i think
joe biden kind of does that obviously
obama does that i think that's fake and
that's bs and honestly i kind of like
how trump was more real but
is that why they don't like him is it
because like he did like the muslim ban
or
things like that scandal where like
locker room talk i'm just curious like
obviously you can't question liberals
but why do they think this exactly
they
hate trump in particular because trump
offered an actual alternative
to the uniparty consensus
and because he was relatively very
effective
the republicans and the democrats
support different things they have
different
policy prescriptions to some degree they
seem to be in opposition but very often
the parties work together
for instance a lot of republicans talk
to game on immigration
but they secretly supported immigration
and the reason for that is because their
donors in the chamber of commerce want
the cheap labor and another reason for
that is they want to keep the
entitlement programs solvent and you
can't do that we were just talking about
abortion and contraception in our dying
population that we've had for 50 years
you need
a massive influx of immigrants if you
want to keep those programs afloat you
want to keep the gdp where it's at or
growing so the democrats want mass
migration because it gives them an
electoral advantage usually gives them
an electoral advantage and the
republicans say they don't want mass
migration but they never do anything to
stop mass migration because they benefit
and and in particular their donors
benefit that would be one one example
when you get to something like
abortion there are a lot of elected
republicans who might have talked a good
game on abortion but they didn't
actually do the things that would be
necessary to stop abortion in america
one reason for that is they were able to
fundraise very well off of abortion on
issues like american manufacturing the
american worker democrats sold out the
american worker a long time ago when
they adopted a full-throated globalism
and outsourced a lot of jobs republicans
did the very same thing
so on an issue like free trade and
outsourcing the republicans and the
democrats pretty much agreed with one
another
and on and on and on and then trump
comes in there and on immigration he
actually offered a different answer
some
significantly different than what you
were hearing from other republicans he
actually said i'm going to build the
wall i'm going to deport people i'm
going to make it more difficult for
people to come over and in the early
days of the trump administration you saw
mass migration decrease dramatically on
an issue like free trade he offered a
totally different answer on free trade
and tariffs than the uniparty had
offered
so that really bugged them democrats are
fine with republicans who are court
jester conservatives who put up a little
bit of a show of opposition
but they actually when push comes to
shove they just concede they they lose
with dignity they don't have any dignity
but they say we're gonna lose with
dignity okay and and that's fine by them
the democrats are okay with they'll
pretend that they they hate them but
really they're okay the liz cheney's the
adam kinzingers the mitt romneys those
kinds of people
when a republican comes out and is
effective and offers an actual
alternative they're especially going to
hate that republican they're always
going to hate the current republican
whoever the current republican is is
going to be hitler and the past
republicans they're going to have more
of a strange new respect for but trump
is a little bit different because trump
probably just by virtue of his lack of
of elected political experience he just
came in and he said oh i thought we
actually believed all the things we say
we believe i'm going to actually do them
and the republican establishment said no
no that's just the thing we say on the
campaign trail you can't actually do
that stuff and that that in particular
aroused the ire of dems next question
hello again nostradamus last month i
sent a voicemail back asking for advice
to my friend who wants to have a baby
with her without a man i agree with
everything that you said and your
thoughts were really what i wanted to
say but i couldn't articulate them well
i told her ahead of time that i agree
with everything that you said and i
recorded your response and sent it to
her she told me she showed the video to
her therapist her therapist doesn't
agree with her being selfish because in
his view it's not selfish for her to
want a child i feel like her therapist
is too affirming to be a therapist or
even talk about logistics and morality
in this case now she tells me that she
has a fear of men and is still going to
follow her own schedule with the
artificial insemination
she's had less than desirable boyfriends
over the years and i feel like it skewed
her view of men and how she values
herself
despite that she truly does want to get
married one day too man who will come in
and value her she's expressed this to me
and i wish i could be there for her and
support her without being the yes girl i
know it's not my place because i'm not
her parents she's working on her
relationship with her parents again but
as her friend i don't know what to do
thank you for your advice and love the
show
great question why would the thing you
should ask her is
why she would bring this question to her
therapist
why would her therapist
have anything to say about this
why would she bring a question of
morality and bioethics
to a psychologist or a psychiatrist that
would be like bringing a question about
astrophysics to me
i don't know i don't know anything about
astrophysics in as much as i have any
expertise at all it's not in
astrophysics so why would you ask me
likewise the psychologist's job is to
well
we've been a little harsh on
psychologists on the show today haven't
we because tom cruise was more correct
than the entire psychiatric
establishment for 17 years but
but beyond that
let's say because i actually do think
some psychologists
can do important work drew clavin says
his life was saved by a psychologist not
by people just selling pills but by
actual talk therapy so in in as much as
a psychologist has expertise it's on the
way that
your psyche works and the way that you
think about yourself and and the way
that your
your mind is perceiving the world and
your role in the world
right but the
psychologist doesn't know a damn thing
or by by virtue of his education doesn't
know a damn thing about morality or
sexual ethics or
the relationship of a mother to her
child
in a sort of grand moral
scheme she doesn't know anything about
that she really should be bringing that
question to a priest or a pastor but
maybe your friend doesn't have a priest
or a pastor she should be
thinking of that question through the
view of
moral philosophers through perhaps the
view of the bible may i suggest
but today we because we live in a
therapeutic culture because we live in a
culture that ignores objective reality
that frequently denies the objective
moral order that thinks that priests are
just a bunch of witch doctors and
charlatans and shamans we we make
everything about psychology and
psychiatry because that just makes it
all about us and we think that we're the
only people in the world
but if you look at the record especially
of the psychiatric establishment for the
for the i don't know for the past
hundred years but especially for the
past couple of decades
who are the shamans here who are the
witch doctors who are the quacks
it ain't the priests okay it ain't the
moral philosophers
i think it's the people peddling the
therapeutic society next question
good morning smokey mike this is julia
your number one fan girl today i have a
little bit more of a serious question
my best friend is planning on working at
bp starting august 1st as an engineer
this will be her first
job as an engineer however she just
found out that bp
is paying for its employees
abortions she's a very devout catholic
very pro-life she wouldn't even get the
fauciauchi because of the abortion
um connections that it had so you can
just imagine her moral qualms in this
situation as well
my question is do you think that it
would be morally okay for her to work at
bp while they're paying for their
employees abortions or should she seek
employment elsewhere thank you so much i
look forward to your answer
short answer is i do think it would be
morally okay
but it is a moral question the reason i
think it's okay
is because we're discussing not a direct
engagement with evil but an indirect
participation with evil you're working
for a company and the company has a
certain insurance policy and the
insurance policy covers travel for
people who want to go get abortions
which is very very bad but it's pretty
indirect
i
i suspect most companies in the country
if not the vast majority of companies in
the country have similar policies
or will institute similar policies in
the wake of the dobbs decision
i think the government i'm certain the
government has that policy
many governments so does that mean that
it's it would be immoral to work a
government job i i don't
necessarily think so the military pays
for abortions does that mean it's
immoral to serve in the american
military
at a certain
at a certain point uh i think the the
participation
is so indirect and and the presence of
this is so ubiquitous that uh
it would be licit to do so uh but
should she
i don't know i mean that that's a
question for her what what
degree of participation and evil is she
willing to
tolerate to exist in the world
if if my company if i were working for a
company that were going out
and
promoting abortion sponsoring planned
parenthood donating lots of money to
planned parenthood having them i i
probably would quit and go to a company
that was a little bit more sane but if
we're talking about essentially
insurance policies and benefits i just
don't know how you can avoid that in the
modern world and as long as the the
participation's indirect perhaps it's
tolerable all right last voicemail back
question
hello michael i'm not a long time
listener i'm not a fan in fact i do not
support your work in any way my name is
dr ann lesbie and i am a gender studies
professor at acl university when i'm not
educating in the classroom i dedicate my
free time to educating the ignorant on
twitter and exposing dangerous
right-wing transphobic fascists such as
yourself
here's my question considering the havoc
you wreak daily on vulnerable groups
such as drag children's performers and
sex workers of color
how do you sleep at night
really great great question ann lesbie
dr lesby
one of my favorite twitter accounts i i
would encourage anyone who is not
already following dr lesbi
uh dr lesbi kama ann to follow her
account
i'm really glad to hear your voice
that's that's great how do i sleep at
night
uh with the great comfort of a helix
mattress that that is how i sleep at
night uh let's get to some written mail
bag before we go question from caden i
am a christian white man who knows i'm a
man and i'm in need of some advice about
to start my freshman year of college
i'll be staying in the dorms because my
scholarship will help pay for that
problem is that i got an email from one
of my assigned suitemates telling me
that she is transgender this is a girl
who thinks she's a boy in the boy's
dorms meaning i would have to share a
bathroom with this person
there's no way that i'm going to room
with this person do you have any advice
on how i should proceed without getting
canceled and losing the scholarships i
have i'm an all-access member from
oklahoma love the show
thank you for everything that you are
doing on the culture front tricky
question
i guess i would file for a religious
exception it's silly that you have to
make this a religious matter but
transgenderism is a religious matter and
that's not your religion you have a
different religion i imagine and so
that's what i would i would ask for and
i would do it politely i wouldn't make a
big stink and start protesting before
you even make it to campus he who pays
the piper calls the tune and the
university is paying for this stuff
but i agree with you i think that
situation is probably intolerable and
so
i wouldn't do it it's just it's just
wrong men and women should not be living
in the same suite together no matter
what their professed sexual desires are
so or their gender identity or whatever
so i would do that i would this is one
where i think you probably catch
more bees with honey than with vinegar
but i would hold your ground on this and
and maybe start looking at some backup
plans too would be would be my it's
always good to be prepared always good
to have an off ramp okay
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show have a good
weekend i'll see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin